we all know
joe biden is corrupt we all know that
his corruption
involves his son hunter biden we know
that hunter
and very possibly joe were involved in
ukraine
and china and other places around the
world we know that a lot of this has
come to light
because of hunter biden's laptop beyond
that the issue gets a little bit
confusing it helps to go back to the
very
beginning of this sordid tale of
corruption
try to put the pieces together into a
timeline because when you see the
timeline clearly
it looks so much worse than all of the
rumors that are floating around right
now
in 2014 during the obama administration
joe biden is vice president and he meets
with his son hunter biden's business
partner devin archer
at the white house five days later
joe biden visits ukraine he is described
in ukraine
as the administration's point person on
all ukrainian issues
that was five days later the day after
that
devin archer joins the board of burisma
burisma is a
notoriously infamously corrupt ukrainian
energy company now six days after that
british officials seize the assets of
barrisma's owner because burisma's
corruption does not just involve ukraine
it involves the entire international
community this is a notorious
organization two weeks after that hunter
biden
also joins the board of burisma what a
coincidence
these two business partners from america
who have absolutely no
experience in energy no experience in
ukraine don't speak the language
have no business being there somehow
join the board
wonder why all of this after white house
meeting
between archer and joe biden devin
archer and hunter biden
would be paid millions of dollars by
burisma
over the next several years now around
the same time
the u.s government approved the sale of
u.s military technology
to a chinese company that has ties to
the chinese government
most chinese companies have ties to the
chinese government some
more so than others and this one in
particular
one of the companies that was involved
in that transaction was a company called
rosemont seneca partners who owned
rosemont seneca partners you guessed it
hunter biden there he is again he must
be a business genius
it wasn't just hunter biden who owned
rosemont seneca partners it was also
john kerry's stepson now there's a lot
of strange coincidences here between the
government
and these business entities and crooked
deals going around
overseas joe biden vice president and
john kerry secretary of state in the
obama administration
both involved in a major major deal
overseas that involves the sale
of u.s military technology ultimately to
the chinese government
emails now reveal that the obama
administration
knew about hunter biden's involvement
and ignored
the conflict of interest u.s officials
in ukraine u.s officials at the state
department
repeatedly raised concerns to the
administration they said this is not a
good look
this is going to come back and bite us
how can we clean up corruption in
ukraine
when you've got the vice president's son
on the board of one of the most corrupt
companies in ukraine
what did the administration do the
administration continually ignored
all of these complaints all of these
concerns john kerry
and joe biden both lied and said that
they had no knowledge
of their family's involvement in the
crooked deals we now
in fact know that they knew very well
of their son's involvement in these
issues also during this time
hunter biden received a 3.5 million
dollar wire transfer
from the wife of the former mayor of
moscow totally normal right run of the
mill
certainly hunter biden has some
expertise in russian affairs right
certainly hunter biden speaks the
russian language certainly hunter biden
has
any credential to his name whatsoever
right wrong
very strange gets a three and a half
million dollar wire transfer from one of
the richest women
in russia hunter biden also opened a
bank account with a chinese oligarch to
fund a global spending spree
with his corrupt uncle jim biden
he received millions of dollars in cash
flow from other corrupt
chinese figures
at this point you say okay hunter biden
and jim biden they don't sound like
great guys
but how does this relate to joe well
while
joe was the obama administration's point
man on ukraine
joe biden pressured the ukrainian
government to fire a prosecutor
who had been investigating corruption at
burisma
you don't need to take my word for this
joe biden actually bragged about his
role in the firing
at the council on foreign relations in
january of 2018.
joe biden threatened to withhold one
billion dollars in military aid from
ukraine
while ukraine was at war with russia if
the then
ukrainian president petro poroshenko did
not fire this prosecutor
the prosecutor who was investigating the
crooked company that joe biden's son
served on the board of joe said if the
prosecutor is not fired
you're not getting the money well son of
a [ __ ] he got fired
those are joe's own words from council
on foreign relations
joe biden and his supporters have tried
to spin this admission
he tried to say oh that was completely
unrelated to investigations into burisma
that was simply because we were trying
to get out corruption in ukraine and
actually
that prosecutor was corrupt even though
the prosecutor was investigating the
corruption of bharisma they're trying to
flip it
we now know that the administration was
well aware of the conflict of interest
we know that they were well aware of
hunter biden's involvement
we know government officials repeatedly
raised concerns about it
so you've got to ask yourself this one
question even beyond
all of those why would the vice
president of the united states
care so much about a prosecutor in
ukraine
why would he tie military aid while
russia was invading
to the firing of some random prosecutor
because joe
just has this hobby horse about
corruption in ukraine
i don't think so he has involvement i
think in corruption in ukraine
but it's not about rooting it out
for a long time joe biden pretended not
to know
anything about hunter's business
dealings but hunter
unfortunately for joe undercut all of
these denials
when hunter admitted in a new yorker
interview that he had spoken about the
deals to joe
and that joe had actually told him quote
i hope
you know what you're doing hunter then
admitted this in a tv interview
though if you watch the clip you can see
he quickly realizes
that he wasn't supposed to make this
admission so he tried to walk it back
he said here's what my father and i said
i mean we never had a conversation and
then the interviewer says
well did you did you have the
conversation or you did well it was a
little bit but it wasn't a conversation
that's all
so did joe know or didn't he we now know
with 100 certainty that joe did know
thanks to a report from the new york
post which social media platforms most
notably twitter
are doing their damnedest to suppress
just a few weeks ago
the post published a trove of emails
obtained
from a computer that hunter biden very
stupidly abandoned at a repair shop
the emails show a top burisma executive
thanking hunter biden
for introducing him to his father less
than a year before
joe biden pressured ukraine to fire the
prosecutor that was investigating
barrisma
so much for joe not knowing about the
business deals
joe actually met the crooked business
associates involved
other emails discovered on that laptop
suggest that hunter biden
may have been giving up to half of his
payoffs to joe
that he took other crooked deals for the
family from china as well
so are the emails legitimate or not we
know the emails are legitimate because
the biden campaign
has refused to deny them that's first of
all second of all
the documents also contain photos of
hunter biden
in compromising positions let's say with
crack pipes and strange women
so either the files are legitimate or
the russian operatives that we're
talking about
are the most sophisticated photo
shoppers on the planet that was the
first
denial by the mainstream media they said
these are russian hackers well
that doesn't hold a lot of water either
because the fbi and the director of
national intelligence have both said
that this is not a russian
disinformation effort these
files are legitimate that takes you
through
a bit of the scandal hunter biden from
the very beginning
actively working on these crooked deals
joe knew about it the obama
administration knew about it
joe biden was actively involved in
procuring the deals that we know that's
established
so what's the bottom line will any of
this affect the election
some conservatives have focused on the
lurid drug and sex photos
to attack hunter i think this is a
mistake
everyone knows somebody who has dealt
with drug addiction especially these
days
where there is an opioid crisis few
people are scandalized by weird sex
stuff these days too
the photos frankly are more sad than
shocking
they serve the purpose of authenticating
the hard drive that's fine
but i'm not so sure that conservatives
should focus too much on them
the evidence of the corruption is much
more damning but even so i'm not sure
that that will affect the results of the
election
we all know that joe biden is corrupt
he's been a liar and a crook in public
life for nearly 50 years
he had to drop out of the 1988
presidential election because he was
caught lying and plagiarizing speeches
in the 1970s joe biden's brother jim
received generous loans
from lenders when joe took a seat on the
senate banking committee
joe was in regular contact with those
banks and discouraged them from trying
to collect on his brother
in the 90s a group of trial lawyers who
would later go to prison for bribery
paid jim biden to lobby through his
brother on their behalf in washington
and then the de resistance during the
obama years
jim biden received a one and a half
billion dollar contract
for construction in iraq despite having
no experience in construction
or any rock but does any of that matter
we all know joe is a corrupt politician
we all know that he's a
swamp creature par excellence been in
washington 47 years
i suspect the corruption scandals will
probably not affect joe
in the same way that mean tweets and
rumors about porn stars never hurt
donald trump
biden's corruption and trump's reality
tv antics are built into the calculation
more likely this isn't a persuasion
election at all it's all about turnout
who can bring out the most votes the
only corruption one can fear
is who counts those votes in the
election